um i hate to say it but the world we
live in social media um
they
crave negativity
you put up
uh something you're doing something
positive whatever
i like i feel like uh worcester brother
trader truth should get
millions
of likes and views of course man he's
one of the realest there's so much for
his community for his community he's got
relief games some relief games yep
relief gang with him and mr rogers right
you see he get his he get it as little
perks because a lot of people with blue
checks might be on there right but i
think
what traitor truth does
deserves the millions of you i feel like
traitor truth should have 40 million
followers facts right yeah
but then you go over here to the other
dude
right
that got less followers but he may
promote a fight or say yo
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that or this this and
that and that's where all the traffic
goes unfortunately that's the world we
live in that's what it is and i
understand that i understand that to be
entertainment
see a lot of these people take this [ __ ]
too seriously too real that's like the
news if you think about the news the
ratings for the news were the highest
when trump was in office straight up
because
they they want the controversy this dude
the controversy he's gonna say some
crazy he's gonna say some wild [ __ ]
every day
new cnn twitter instagram
and then and and and whether you're on
the left or the right or in the middle
there's a channel for you to go and
there goes reaffirm what you feel and
there you go a lot of this
a lot of this [ __ ] be entertainment you
know what i'm saying a lot of it is
entertainment because we know we have to
entertain you know what i mean we know
what what what what they want to see
what they don't want do you look at
yourself as an entertainer now kind of
because you're you're kind of a social
media you know people i think i think my
i think my entertainment kicks in
because the things i say and address
is borderline with the negativity
that might lead to violence
so it's something for them to talk about
because i think that you are looked at
like
for people who don't even know who the
[ __ ] you are as far as what you do in
the industry
people just fought like there's people
who were following you just because they
saw some wild [ __ ] you might have seen
exactly they don't maybe respect or
understand they see me i have a fight i
didn't want to have a [ __ ] fight i'm
telling the world i didn't want to have
a fight i didn't go to the burger stand
that day they had a fight
it's a fight that just happened i didn't
[ __ ] record the fight there's just
somebody out there with a goddamn camera
right recording something and then it
went right but
that thing got a hundred two hundred
thousand guys that wasn't crazy and it's
not even the first time you've knocked
someone out on camera shout out to
stitches
i mean i had a million fights right
right right because they saw it then
that's just what that is right but
that's what the people want that's what
they crave i don't i why i was sitting
watching chick film with my wife because
that's my wife right
man put on some [ __ ] with them dudes
jumping out the helicopter this [ __ ]
just got bombed the drones came in look
that's what i want to see right that's
what excites me and i think that's just
what excites people you know that's why
when you see a lot of these rappers when
they um become other things and they
start shining away from it
you don't hear jay-z's name unless he
didn't drop the verse a crazy verse or
he didn't brought another company a guy
doesn't bring down a check straight up
you don't hear no way